avec vos vidal tard abaissé ce matin
bonjour bilal bonjour pauline on le
disait dans le journal ce jeudi marque
donc le premier mois de l'invasion russe
de l'ukraine 4 semaines de combats sur
le terrain d'abord quel bilan on peut
tirer de ce mois de guerre eh bien
écoutez l'armée russe d'abord contrôler
deux villes elles sont au sud il s'agit
de kherson et de mélie topol et l'armée
russe contrôle un terrain on le voit sur
cette carte en rouge bordeaux 1 sur le
pourtour est qui fait 49 mille
kilomètres carrés c'est à dire que même
à peu près la taille du danemark en
revanche clairement ce qu'on peut dire
au bout d'un mois de guerre en ukraine
c'est que cette armée russe elle est
enlisée vous voyez cette carte elle a
quasiment pas bougé depuis le 4 5 mars
c'est à dire depuis une semaine à peu
près après le début de l'offensive russe
on a au nord tchernihiv soumis karkhiv
bien sûr qui résiste toujours mario paul
qui a siégé qui n'est toujours pas
tombée nicolas yves qui barrent toujours
la route pour aller à odessa ici est
toujours kiev qui est partiellement
encerclée mais qui reste aux mains aux
mains du gouvernement est ce qu'il est
juste du coup de dire que les russes ont
peut-être sous-estimé la capacité de
résistance des ukrainiens il est
certainement juste de dire que vladimir
poutine a sous-estimé la capacité de
résistance des des ukrainiens alors
tombée on veut je vous propose de
regarder ces images on voit ces colonnes
de chars russes qui sont vous le voyez
sur le goudron parce qu'ils ne peuvent
pas en fait allé sur les côtés de la
route à cause du dégel c'est un
phénomène qui est très connu qui
s'appelle la race foutiste à et vous le
voyez à force de rester sur les routes
ici eh bien ils sont la cible deux
missiles anti chars et des snipers russe
c'est un phénomène biologique et de
sniper ukrainien évidemment c'est un
film phénomène météo qui est très connu
en ukraine ça prouve bien que vladimir
poutine pensait arriver à contrôler le
pays de manière beaucoup plus rapide que
ça on peut aussi citer la résistance de
car qui vainquit une ville russophones
et dont certains auraient pu croire
qu'elle accueillerait
l'armée russe avec des fleurs ça n'a pas
du tout été le cas puisque elle résiste
encore jusqu'à aujourd'hui on rentre
donc aujourd'hui dans la cinquième
semaine de conflit quels sont les
différents scénarios de la façon dont
les les sur le terrain les choses
peuvent évoluer alors très difficile de
prévenir l'avenir il ya quand même deux
choses qui paraissent assez sens et la
première serait que vladimir poutine
cherche à s'emparer de tout le sud ici
ça correspond à un projet d'état qui
s'appelait la nouvelle russie et qui
avait été proposé par les premiers
dirigeants du dombass il y à aussi la
forte probabilité que l'armée russe
cherche à établir une ligne verticale
soit de mario pas là car qu'ils soient
de mélie topal à kharkhiv cette fois ci
pour prendre tout l'est ça permettrait à
vladimir poutine de prendre à la fois
l'industrie et les terres fertiles de
l'ukraine et de dire qu'il a mis en
sécurité les populations du dombass
comme on sait rien il justifie sa guerre
pour les protéger d'un selon ses termes
génocide la guerre a bien souvent ce
sont certains qu'il a décidé d'autres
qui la subissent la situation
humanitaire en ukraine c'est quand
quatre semaines bilal un ukrainien sur
quatre a dû quitter l endroit où ils
vivaient tout à fait on peut même dire
que un ukrainien sur dix a fui un son
domicile il y à 3,6 millions de réfugiés
ukrainien pour une population de 37
millions on le voit sur cette carte un
la pologne à elles seules accueille la
moitié des réfugiés ukrainien c'est
quand même plus de 2 millions 100 mille
personnes il y a dans le désordre 1 la
hongrie la roumanie la slovaquie bien
sûr frontaliers la moldavie ici on a des
réfugiés en russie et alors là ce
chiffre ici je le découvre un n'est pas
exact il ya à peu près 4000 réfugiés
ukrainien en biélorussie ce qui n'est
évidemment pas grand chose je vous donne
simplement cette dernière information
selon les nations unies
90 % de ces réfugiés sont des femmes et
des enfants qui sans compter et c'est
pour ça que je lisais quatre ukrainiens
travail en tout en comptant les déplacés
internes on arrive à plus de 10 millions
de déplacés d'ukrainiens merci beaucoup
bilal c'était votre décryptage il est